Lions Serials den kindheitsklassiker
gibt es inzwischen auch als Riegel von
Nestlé wird er als vollwertiges
Frühstück beworben sebastian hat da
seine Zweifel das sind ein paar
vollkornkeksbrösel mit dem zuckermantel
und mit einer Fettschicht hinten drauf
er baut das vermeintliche Frühstück nach
und zeigt welche ungesunden Zutaten in
dem schlummern
[Applaus]
guten Morgen
das hier nenne ich mal ein vollwertiges
Frühstück
Haferflocken Saft Joghurt richtig lecker
und gib mir Energie für den ganzen Tag
und genau das hier sind die Alternativen
der Lebensmittelindustrie
Frühstück von Nestlé die Packungen
versprechen Vollkorn und viele Vitamine
mit Kuh oder Pflanzenmilch wird daraus
ein süßes Frühstück
die laien-serialien bestehen zu einem
Viertel aus Zucker
wir haben aber noch einen drauf gesetzt
das Ganze im Handyformat ja ich brauche
mich gar nicht mehr an den Tisch setzen
halbe Stunde länger pennen ganz um
Riegel der Slogan Frühstück ja Löffel
nein
nestless
und Nesquik gibt es jetzt am Morgen ohne
Milch und ohne Geschirr
da machst du das auf
und dann glänzerst Teil wie aus der
Autolackiererei
außen eine glänzende Schicht unten ein
weißer Boden dazwischen dunkle und helle
Flocken
Zusatzstoff Zusatzstoff Zusatzstoff
alter Schwede
drin ist
Riegel als erste mal Zeit für den Tag
der Frühstücks Trick
[Musik]
dieser kleine Riegel hat diese ganzen
Zutaten glauben sie nicht doch stimmt im
Laien frühstücksriegel stecken über 30
verschiedene Zutaten darunter Glukose
Sirup Fett und Schokolade
cerealie hört sich ja immer schön gesund
an und auf vitalisierend ist wie war so
mühst wie für die Hand
meinen sie
den Begriff serialien hat die
Lebensmittelindustrie mit Werbung
bekannt gemacht
klingt natürlich erstmal relativ
kompliziert und auch wissenschaftlich
und hat leicht einen gesunden Touch aber
das Wort bedeutet eigentlich nur
Frühstücksflocken und das umfasst
einerseits die sehr gesunden
Haferflocken aber auch stark gezuckerte
Cornflakes
Produktentwickler Sebastian lege zeigt
was in den Cerealien für den laienriegel
steckt
und jetzt machen wir unsere kleinen
Knusper Cerealien
Vollkornmehl Reismehl
Mais
Calciumcarbonat
und mit unsere Cerealien auch richtig
schick werden auf der Verpackung kommt
noch ein paar Vitamine dazu natürlich
Pantothensäure Folsäure riboflavin B6
und Niacin und schon sieht die
Zutatenliste gleich viel versprechender
aus jetzt brauchen wir noch ein bisschen
Weizenmehl ne weil das ganze soll ja
schön zusammenkleben
Zucker sehr gut ne
Salz da kommt wirklich nur ein bisschen
rein dazu mal du extrem ein Zuckerstoff
der in der Industrie auch als filmmittel
dient und als emulgationshilfe so
reality
Emulgatoren helfen dabei dass ich alle
Stoffe gut miteinander verbinden
[Musik]
mit Wasser und Öl werden die Zutaten zu
einem festen Brei
das sieht eher aus wie Keksteig und das
soll ein gesunde Cerealien werden
[Gelächter]
das müssen wir den Teig einmal nur in
Schokoladenteig verwandeln und den
anderen lassen wir so wie er ist sei ja
auch noch toll aussehen ne noch sieht
der Teig wenig appetitlich aus ein Teig
bleibt hell der andere bekommt durch
Kakaopulver die richtige Farbe eine
kleine Menge reicht für den Geschmack
hat Sebastian eine billigere Zutat
Schokoladen Aroma
ey der wird immer klebriger der Teig
hier was neues kann die Schale kann
nicht so hochheben
was kann man doch nicht essen
das erinnert mich an was ganz anderes
mit einem Spritzbeutel setzt Sebastian
lege hunderte kleine teigkleckse helle
und dunkel sie backen im Ofen und werden
knusprig
da sind die kleinen Mäuse
[Musik]
Cerealien Bäckerei die Industrie benutzt
große Maschine
jetzt muss das ganze Jahr irgendwie
zusammenhalten das muss ein Riegel
werden und was klebt am besten raten Sie
mal
Zucker und ja ja nicht nur eine
Zuckerart Glukose Sirup läutet Zucker
frukto Oligosaccharide
invertzuckersirup und
karamellzuckersirup für die Haltbarkeit
sorgt ein Antioxidationsmittel
und
Glycerin sorgt für die Bindung
und ein bisschen Schokolade für die
Farbe
denken Sie daran Frühstück
okay geht weiter Haferflocken
Haferflocken sagte unsere Mutter schon
das ist gesunde
4,3% Haferflocken stecken in einem
original-riegel damit alles zusammenhält
muss die Zuckermischung die kleinen
Teilchen umhüllen dann kann Sebastian
lege sie in Form pressen und ab in die
Kühlung
[Musik]
der Riegel ist hart fehlt nur noch die
weiße Unterseite die hat Sebastian lege
aus läutet sogar Magermilchpulver
Kokosfett Kakaobutter und letzithin
angerührt
so ab damit in die Kühlung ja muss er
kalt muss er hart werden
[Musik]
so
das wäre jetzt mal der Riegel für meinen
Frühstück
Schutzbrille safety first ein Riegel ist
10 cm lang und wiegt nur 25 Gramm ganz
schön wenig für einen guten Start in den
Tag
die sind doch richtig gut aus aber
richtig tip top
aber ein vollwertiges Frühstück das sind
ein paar vollkornkeksbrösel mit dem
zuckermantel und mit einer Fettschicht
hinten drauf
und lecker ist das auch nicht
für nestley haben die frühstücksriedel
vor allem einen Vorteil bekannte
Cerealien lassen sich im praktischen
riegelformat deutlich teurer verkaufen
der Preisaufschlag liegt bei 41 bis 71%
[Musik]
der Riegel enthält Zusatzstoffe Fett und
dadurch viele Kalorien trotz 22,4%
Zucker trägt der Regel den nutri Score C
[Musik]